[Music]
feel comfortable in my body
for the probably the first time opening
up like never before elliott sheds what
he calls tears of joy in his first
interview with oprah
streaming tomorrow on the apple tv plus
series the oprah conversations
you were suffering depression anxiety
panic attacks
it wasn't good can you describe the
feeling that came up that then said
i'm going to declare this i came out as
as gay right before my 27th birthday and
up until
then i had pretty much never even
touched someone outside who i was in
love with you know
and so i think any kind of sensation of
feeling that again
i there was just no way i could do it
it felt important and selfish for myself
and my own well-being and my mental
health and knowing the pain and the
difficulties and the struggles i faced
in my life
let alone what so many other people are
facing
it absolutely felt just crucial and
important for me
elliot who has gone top surgery also
explains what it feels like to finally
feel comfortable in his own skin
what part of your transition has
actually brought you
the most joy i'm not having the moment
where i'm panicked
i'm not having all these little moments
that used to be
just being in a t-shirt getting out of
the
shower and the towels around your waist
and you're looking at yourself in the
mirror and you're just like
there i am